I'm doing a more sophisticated Jersey
poof its 2019 so I'm not abandoning my
roots I'm just like replanting No hi my
name is Grace help me you do not know
now you know your life is different now
that's right today the Q&A video I went
on my Instagram story because I'm young
and hip and relevant that's you guys for
questions that you wanted me to answer
and so that's what we're doing today
it's also only been a little over an
hour since I asked you to submit your
questions so that's preferred get my
worms
I might have worms goose it I know I
don't trust that's my job if you don't
know hi welcome you're new here let's
just get into this and start paying some
Q's shall we how's the nose ring lost
anymore stud no I have not I currently
have a nose ring in that's one of the
screw one my nose is basically like a
bottle of Cabernet it's weird
so no but we'll see I'm constantly
worried this is gonna push through and
I'm gonna like swallow that completely
and I'm gonna freak the shout I don't
know who's gonna help me it was the last
time you've seen your ob/gyn doctor did
my mother get an Instagram handle as
simply crazy girl I mean within the last
year I should probably schedule
something Siri remind me to go see my
ob/gyn doctor within the next month for
simply crazy girl okay it was actually
extremely helpful
any advice for turning 30 I'm actually
terrified I've talked about this a bunch
on podcast the movie dirty thirty it
dresses this directly I forget my age
constantly maybe that's a me problem and
not something that you deal with but
thirty is not a troublesome age if
anything it should be the most
empowering thing ever because you have
so much more perspective than you did at
20 I would say congratulations you're 30
now's the time when you have the most
fun within reason
because your body hurts a little bit
more now than it did before what type of
sandwich is your favorite I love
meatball hoagie from Wawa Shane come for
me is it sure that you and Phil DeFranco
dated yes sorry I thought you said is it
true that you and Phil DeFranco are
dated which is is true we are old people
on the internet have we dated no no no
have you seen Lindy there are you
writing another book
I loved your first two I want to write a
third book I should be writing a third
book it has been difficult to write a
third book I am figuring out what the
third book would be but I want to the
big answer is have you ever done drugs
yes where have you gone it feels like
you've disappeared from YouTube in the
last six months
yeah for sure I'm tired I don't have a
huge like team around me making video
the only obligation is to myself I want
to make videos that I want to make like
this and I don't want to force myself
into a schedule that I subconsciously
know I won't keep because that's not
fair to you you guys all have your mommy
and daddy issues I'm not gonna
contribute to that at least I'm gonna
try not to contribute what's the most
impossible thing you've ever done I got
this tattoo in Vancouver with Hannah 3
or 4 a.m. you can read all about it in
her book it's fully blurred and you
can't even read the words that are on it
anymore but the intention was real sweet
who's your favorite person that you've
had on the podcast oh well obviously you
guys know I love Chelsea Handler but
Tony Hale oh my god I don't think that
episode will be up by the time this
video goes up holy [ __ ] I was so nervous
and he was so incredibly kind and so
incredibly present and thoughtful and he
just has such beautiful insight and
thought ruminations about anxiety
celebrity life in general and it was it
was so wonderful I cannot wait for you
guys to hear that episode cooped on
anyone's lawn lately not that I remember
what is your favorite piece of advice
you've ever been given the idea of just
have fun as simple as it is is so
impactful to me especially at this point
in my life now remember you only live
once so if you can enjoy doing the
things that you're doing it is so
absolutely wonderful this is a piece of
advice that I need to take more often
have fun make things silly products you
use every
what do I use every day hold on okay
here's a microcosm of what I use every
day Mario Badescu skincare facial spray
with aloe cucumber and green tea I don't
know if it does jack but I feel
refreshed when I spray it on my face and
I feel like I'm a fancy lady that could
go to spa sometimes but definitely
doesn't I sprayed myself with this is
our black amber scent every day there's
only 3.4 fluid ounces so I can travel
with this hell yeah we're learning
together I also use this dr. Brandt
needles no more no more baggage i deep
puffing gel and then also this is what I
really want to talk to you guys about
this is coolest and something I
absolutely need in my life and has made
a very obvious difference Kara
you guys have probably heard about this
brand from other people they're
influencers etc Carib is a subscription
service that makes super easy for you
guys to get vitamins protein powders
whatever health thing you're looking for
personalized just for you and delivered
right to your door every month and you
go to the website they have an online
quiz that you fill out super easy but
you have to be honest with them about it
what you want I've always been extremely
apprehensive about going to a
nutritionist because I felt like if they
heard my actual like diet and everyday
lifestyle or routine they'd be like so
you're the Crypt Keeper I don't know how
to help you with that your quiz asked
you about like your diet your health
goals your lifestyle choices it takes
like five minutes to fill out and then
the results provide you with like
personal scientifically backed vitamins
protein powders like I said etcetera
things that are catered tailored just
for you for the needs that you want miss
going to any health food store and just
going through the Isles of vitamins I
have no [ __ ] clue but they do they
also have vegan and vegetarian
supplements available and then if you
like what they've recommended you can
say yes and then they send you this
little pack that is tailor-made just for
you and it's a 30-day pack where there's
30 of these little vitamin packs it's
the cutest thing and it makes me feel
special so fun to wake up in the morning
and go excuse me I gotta go be an adult
right now I'll be right back this is my
kind of drug deal but also because
they're sponsoring this video obviously
you guys get a discount you 25% off your
first order by going to take care of
comm and using the promo code
race age what's your fav thing about
your bf I can fit in his jeans
what mascara are you wearing loving
those spider legs thank you
I believe it's Tarte lights camera
flashes mayhaps you send me some free
product given what's something you are
proud of accomplishing but never get to
bring up in condos I'm I really proud of
going to therapy again it's not
something I necessarily look forward to
every week but I know it's good for me
it's like brain exercise and I'm really
proud of sticking to it if you are
afraid or hesitant to that usually means
if there's a pretty big reason you
should yeah that's cute which shirts
from your merch should I buy I'm
indecisive ass and can't pick all of the
shirts link in the description how often
does your butt itch like at least once a
week well that's it for this edition of
Q&A with gray thank you guys so much for
your questions on instagram if you guys
want to participate in these sorts of
videos in the future follow me at grace
Helbig across everything turn on that
Bell notification however that you do it
because I make videos other than that I
don't know what's the normal spectrum of
but at jury where are you guys at leave
a comment down below that's the only
thing I want you guys to comment